well if you saw my original Disney
semper review of 101 Dalmatians you
probably won't be that shocked that I
think pretty much the same thing about
the live-action one which is funny
because in many respects it is exactly
like the original and yet completely
different the story is exactly the same
the characters are exactly the same the
setting is exactly the same but there is
however one major difference the dogs
don't talk a lot of people I remember
when this was coming out we're really
angry and shocked at that oh my god how
can the dogs not talk they talked in the
original holy smokes and what's it all
about - well very much like the anime
one is just a movie about watching
puppies and if you like to watch puppies
you'll like this film fine the story
centers around a male Dalmatian and his
owner played by Jeff Daniels who has his
eye on a female Dalmatian who has a
pretty attractive owner as well of
course both the dogs and the humans meet
up and they decide to get together over
time they get married and eventually the
female dog gets pregnant giving birth to
15 adorable puppies but an evil villain
in karela de Ville played by Glenn Close
wants to buy the puppy so she can turn
them into fur coats when the owners tell
her that they're not for sale she hires
two henchmen one of them played by Hugh
Laurie to kidnap the puppies and add
them to her collection that's right a
collection for she plans to make tons of
fur coats out of tons of puppies 99 to
be exact when the parents as well as
other animals catch word the race is on
to see if they can save the puppies
before their turn to defection
statements on the one hand I say to
myself this is a completely pointless
movie to exist did this really demand to
be brought to the live-action cinema but
with that said if you had to bring it to
live-action cinema I actually think it's
pretty reasonably done I really applaud
the fact that they don't have them talk
not only was the technology not up to it
back then I mean they could move the
lips but they look at a creepy but the
movie knows exactly what the people want
they just want to see cute dogs and if
they start talking it would just be
really weird and distracting thus we
have to rely on the charm of the human
characters which for the most part hold
out pretty well I mean for such big
parts that have little to on they
actually
got some really good actors to bring him
to life the romantic couple are good the
henchmen are good and yeah let's talk
about Glenn closest relative ill on the
one hand I should be really angry at
this performance because yeah Cruella
Deville isn't over the top character but
this is really over the top
guerrilla was an angry bitter woman this
is just a laughing lunatic she's more
like a 60s Batman villain than she is a
Disney villain and God doesn't that
sound weird to say she's making animated
Disney villains look subtle however with
that said she just cracks me the fuck up
it's kind of like a female Tim Curry or
Christopher Walken there's just no doubt
that she's doing whatever the hell she
wants I mean look at her she's totally
off her rocker if we make this coat it
would be as if I were wearing your dog
how can you not crack off this may be
the way to look at it is not that she
absolutely captured the original
animated character but she turned it
into something 100% different and just
ran all the way with it hell ran to the
fucking moon with it she's so
over-the-top Mike who's a puppy coach
I just can't stop laughing at her she's
a fucking riot for what it is the film
is really not that bad it's 100%
serviceable I can't really see anyone
going into this movie being incredibly
disappointed I mean what do you think
you're going to see you're gonna see
Glenn Close over the top and you're
gonna see cute puppies that's it and as
that setup goes it's obvious they put a
lot of effort into it I think the only
people that would really want to see
them talk are the same people that go
see Santa Paws but I give this movie
credit that it tries to be visually
interesting it tries to cast some good
people it tries to tell Allah the story
through silence which can be very
difficult to do so I guess I appreciate
it more than I actually like it I guess
I like it a little better than the anime
version it's just I didn't really even
get into the anime version that much I
think it's very simple if you really
like dogs especially Dalmatians you'll
really like this and yeah if you just
want to see an actress go batshit insane
it's actually kind of fun to watch for
that - you're looking for a fun little
family film with cute little animals
that's not gonna offend anybody
this definitely hits the spot
you